thing for the for not giving the same
talk like announced in the in the
program
um just because I thought I sent the new
title but I didn't
um but I believe this talk
um maybe is a bit lighter and will be
more entertaining
and also it is about the Minimax theorem
which is useful which is certainly
useful both in learning theory and as
well as in
lower bounds the average case lower
bounds so I believe
I believe this is relevant nevertheless
okay system some people are still coming
in
okay so we'll slowly ah and then another
Advantage is that this this is a joint
work with uh Steve Hanukkah and Royal
livney and Roy livini did make it to the
to the workshop and you can ask him all
the questions you have
happens
sorry if I remember what we did in that
work now he put me in a position
yes that's uh
okay so let's say so let's begin so let
me start with some background
so last year
we were trying to prove a statement
about online learning
and we we managed to do that we found a
proof
which is based on the Minimax theorem
and consequently our proof did not apply
in the most General case you know
infinite hypothesis classes abstract in
the most abstract case
and this is not uncommon in uh in ml
Theory and maybe even in computer
science and usually you just sweep it
under the rug so let me give you a
couple of examples
so um
this is from the paper that uh
introduced the VC Dimension to the to
the west by uh by The Fog by I forget on
the name of the Autos but Manfred valmut
the houseler was there who else
um yeah I don't remember all of them but
let's read it so after vapnik we will
adopt a naive attitude toward
miserability assuming that every set
encountered in our proof is measurable
okay so you take the minimum Sigma
algebra that contains all the set
definable by the paper
uh here is another one from another
paper
in in learning theory some of our
arguments exploit the Minimax theorem
for zero sum games
and therefore we will assume a setting
in which this theorem is valid
alternatively one could State explicit
assumptions such as finiteness or forms
of compactness
under which it is known that the Minimax
theorem holds however we believe that
the presentation benefits from avoiding
such explicit technical assumptions and
simply assuming the Minimax theorem is
an axiom in the discussed setting this
is by the way from people of mine I
wrote this paragraph
um
okay so so sometimes indeed it makes
sense to lose generality in order to
simplify presentation and focus on the
on the key and novel ideas
but the result we'll discuss today was
discovered while attempting to
generalize the result beyond what was
needed sorry can you hear me uh can you
just can you just explain
what is the issue here so you're seeing
the Minimax does not apply in general I
will explain this in more I will explain
it soon in much more detail don't worry
okay okay this is just the background
but what I want to say is that so we
really uh
extended the result Way Beyond what was
needed to be accepted to the conference
and what's interesting is that this side
result we came up with turned out to be
much more popular than the main result
of the paper and even among the
conference people the
so yeah so abstract nonsense sometimes
is uh is nice that's the
that's the takeaway
okay so let's now uh let's now discuss
the Minimax theorem and I think this
will also address the question that I
believe Igor just asked I cannot really
see but
okay so the Minimax theorem let's start
with the way for neumanne
um
thought about this theorem so as far as
I can see there could be no theory of
games without that feeling I thought
there was nothing worth publishing until
the Minimax theorem was proved
um so what so what is the Minimax
theorem let's let's recall this
so we have what is a game okay so we
have we assume we have a we have two
players we call them mini and Max
each of the players has a set of uh of
pure strategies and these are just
abstract sets but you can model with it
uh any game that that has two players
and there is the the rules of the games
which are which are the encoded by this
payoff metrics
right so for every pair of strategies
one strategy for minions one for marks
the payoff metrics
specifies who is the winner so if M of s
and t is one then Max wins So Max wants
to maximize
otherwise if it is zero then mini wins
right so we assume here the
combinatorial setting so there is a
winner and the loser it's not uh it's
not real valued it's uh it's really
combinatorial
and we also allow them to use Randomness
right so um mini and Max can use under
my strategies so many can pick a
distribution of a pure strategies and
Max can pick up distribution over his
um
pure strategies
and we extend the payoff Matrix to one
of my strategies in the obvious way
right so we just take an expectation of
the two independent random draws of
from the mixologies and we look at the
expected value of the of the winning
indicator
okay I guess this should be
familiar to most of you
um
okay so what what is the theorem what is
the Minimax theorem tells us it tells us
that if s and t if the sets of fuel
strategies are finite then this equality
hold so the minimum over P of the
maximum of the Q of the value is equal
to the same expression but in reverse
order so the maximum of a q
of the minimum of the P of the same
value
and let's try to interpret it
so in the in the expression in the left
hand side the mean p Max Q I think we
can think about it as if first mini pxp
first mini declares her strategy then
Max knowing P picks his strategy
and then they play
so max hasn't has an advantage because
he knows which strategy
mini peaked
and in the reverse order many has the
advantage because she plays second
so what the Minimax theorem tells us is
that it doesn't matter who plays first
if for every strategy of the opponent
the existing response that wins with
probability at least V
then there is a universal strategy
that just no matter what the opponent's
place I'm still going to win with
probability at me at least be
are there any questions
okay good
so in in uh so let's uh introduce this
definition so
whenever we have a game that satisfies
the Minimax theorem we Define the value
of the game to be this uh the the common
value of these two expressions
okay so this is the value of the game
okay great
now here is the question that we study
does the Minimax theorem apply to
infinite games
so first of all
um
it is not hard to modify the standard
pool for the Mini Max or to observe that
actually it applies even if only one of
s or t is finite so if only mini or
marks have a finite set then the Minimax
theorem applies
and there are various other other
extensions that assume geometric or even
a more abstract topological structure
and they replace finiteness by
compactness
so the most General format in case is
Scion the Minimax theorem
however there are very simple infinite
games for which the Minimax fails to
hold it doesn't hold
and and the next thing we'll do is we'll
see such a game which was popularized by
a prime kitchen
the frankishoni is a
Hungarian born Israeli
statistics so he wrote a very funny
short stories
and and he and and and he defined the
game that that we're going to discuss
so let me let me Define it by reading a
part of his uh
of his uh related short story and I
recommend all of you to
to read it
at your free time it's available online
okay so let's read it so for quite a
while the two of us set at our table
wordlessly steering our coffee
was bored
alrighty said let's play poker
now I answered I hate cars I always lose
who's talking about cards I was thinking
of Jewish poker he then briefly
explained the rules of the game
Jewish poker is played Without cards in
your head as befits the people of the
book
you think of a number I also think of a
number
whoever thinks of a higher number wins
this sounds easy but it has a hundred
pitfalls all right I agreed let's try
we plank down five pastels each and
leaning back in our church began to
think of numbers
after a while Irving signaled that he
had one I said I was ready
all right let's see your numbers 11 I
said 12 everything said and took the
money I could have kicked myself because
originally I had thought of 14 and only
at the last moment had I climbed down to
11. I really don't know why
listen I turned to Elvin K what would
have happened had I said 14 what a
question I'd have lost
just the charm of Poker you never know
how things will turn out but if your
nerves cannot stand a little gambling
perhaps we had better corridor
without saying another world I put down
10 pastas on the table everything did
likewise I pondered my number carefully
and opened with 18. damn event said I
have only 17 I swept the money into my
pocket and quietly without
certainly not dreamed that I would
Master the text of Duty Focus so quickly
he had probably counted on my opening
with 15 or 16 but certainly not with an
18.
double the stakes as you light as you
like I sneered and could hardly keep
back my jubilant laughter in the
meantime a fantastic number had occurred
to me 35.
lead said Irvin K 35 43 with dirty poker
he pocketed the 40 pieces I could feel
the blood rushing into my brain and it
continues and it's a it's a very very
nice story again I really recommend
reading questions it's a
he's he has very good very nice short
stories like this and
uh yeah it can improve
um
the mood sometimes okay
so let's say let's now present this game
in in our language in in mathematics
so the sets of uh of pure strategies for
both players for Minion marks are the
same these are just natural numbers
and the the pair of Matrix is this
infinite diagonal matrix right so
Whoever has the larger the number wins
and it doesn't we didn't kishan didn't
specify what happens on the diagonal
when they picked the same number
so we just assumed that any assignment
of 0 1 to the diagonal will also be
called the Jewish poker
in our definition
okay
now
this that um
the Jewish pocket does not satisfy
Minimax
right so let's uh let's take a second to
to see that
so what happens if if a mini plays first
so she declares her strategy as a mixed
strategy which is just a distribution of
the natural numbers
but then Marx knowing this distribution
can pick a number far away in the tail
of this distribution and guarantee that
he will win the game with probability as
close to one as he wants
right so if Max plays second
he can go in the the value that you get
in guarantee of winning is as close to
one as he wants by picking numbers far
away in the tail of the distribution
and because the game is symmetric
meaning can do the same thing if she
knows what Max has played first
so we see that there is really a big
difference who plays first
so Minimax doesn't apply to this game
and the main result or not the main
result the side result in our paper was
that this in in some sense Jewish poker
is the only obstacle for a
for the Mini Max so let me be more
formal
so let M be an arbitrary possibly
infinite uncountable no restrictions
whatsoever no structure no geometry no
topology just some game with values in
zero and one
then if the payoff Matrix does not
contain arbitrarily large triangular sub
matrices then the Minimax is satisfied
right so
and contains the submetric series up to
permutations of rows and columns so so
really uh
um so yeah so Contra positively what
this says is that if the Minimax theorem
fails to hold if you found a bad game
that doesn't satisfy the Mini Max then
you can find arbitrarily large sub games
of Jewish poker in it
okay so there is a certificate in for in
the form of an arbitrary loud sub game
of Jewish poker for not satisfying
um the Minimax
now I I I hope to tell you uh something
about the proof
but before that let me present a couple
of open questions but even even before
that let me take questions if anyone has
does it
means
or for any size you have a matrix of sky
is bigger
the the second the latter yeah so so
this is my first open question well I
even dare to say a conjecture is that we
can strengthen this theorem
by saying that
the Minimax applies
even in the case when there are
arbitrarily large sub matrices but there
is no infinite
triangular sub-metrix
so this is a conjecture we don't know
how to prove this
and we prove the weaker form of this
conjunction so we prove that if the
payoff Matrix does not contain
arbitrarily large triangular sub
matrices then the Minimax theorem
applies
so this is indeed uh
uh this this answers your question right
abhishai yeah
good
um yeah so again about about this
conjecture we can think that if the
Minimax theorem fails to hold then
simply it means the Jewish poker is a
sub game of the of our game
okay
um
another it's not really a
formal question it's more like a meta
question is whether there is a finite
manifestation of this theorem that we
just presented
so is there a sense in which finite
games with no large triangular sub
mattresses satisfy a more efficient
version of the Minimax maybe a fish I
don't so you can plug in for efficient
and
and the large you can interpret it in
many ways but one very natural way is
that computational computationally so
efficient in terms of computation maybe
you can compute
an equilibrium for such games faster or
or yeah I don't know
so this is more of a meta question
and
okay and and if there are no so are
there any other questions otherwise I'll
I'll try to say something about the
proof I I kind of have a hard time
thinking I mean how can there be a
you know an infinite Matrix that does
not contain very large
triangular summary system it seems like
to get something triangular
take the infinite identity Matrix right
it will not contain
[Music]
okay but that's not terribly interesting
okay
sorry any symmetrical Matrix
any symmetric metric I'm not sure no not
sure I didn't see matric Matrix will not
contain uh because you know you are also
allowed
the rose and the cones so they're
actually the same that's right
I guess okay
USA game uh any free game on which you
can prove me Max maybe that that will
give me a sense what I don't know if
them I mean I mean take any of course
any finite game satisfied you can just
continue with zeros but you know you can
just think about it as a collection of a
collection of subsets right so um so
each log responds to Let's assume the
domain is natural it's accountable
Matrix so it should always just a subset
of natural numbers so you want an
infinite family of subsets of the
natural numbers that doesn't contain an
infinite chain
when projected to
that that's what it says right yeah okay
okay so you want to so any you know like
like uh anti-chains you know like and
anything like that would be so
combinatory we can describe it easily
but if uh whether I have a natural game
um yeah I don't know I need to think
about it
okay thanks
um any other questions
foreign
so let Let's uh how much time do I have
by the way
maybe 20 25 minutes ah great awesome
great okay so let's let's try to
describe the proof
so this is again the theorem so let M be
any game so we can think about like
discountable metrics if you want
then if the payoff metrics does not
contain arbitrarily large Shrine glass
subnetressors then the Minimax
equality applies
and the proof will will be as follows so
uh
we will assume towards contradiction
that there is a game m
that does not satisfy the Mini Max
yet the largest triangular sub Matrix of
M is of bounded size let's say a hundred
by a hundred
okay so we assume a counter example for
this theorem so it does satisfy the
Minimax but
but it doesn't contain 100 sub matrices
of large of size larger by a hundred
and we will reach a contradiction to
item 2 by showing that m in fact
contains an infinite triangular
sub-matrix
so it will so we will actually show that
M contains Jewish poker as a sub gain
okay so this is the strategy
um and we implement the strategy using
two lemmas
so the first Lemma
which we will prove now
um
tells us that you can find sequences of
sets of strategies so S1 S2 S3 diesel
subsets of strategies of mini and T1 T2
and so on are subsets of strategies of
Max
and all of these subsets are finite and
uniformly bounded by some in the Jody
and
the value when you let s i when you look
at the game induced by let by by letting
the strategies in si against the
strategies in TJ so this is a d by D
Matrix
so the value of this game
is
above some threshold r or below some
threshold R depending on whether I is
less than or greater than J
okay so this this will be the first the
first step in the in the in the proof
and um in the the this the proof of this
Lemma we will use the
um uniform laws of large numbers
[Music]
um
so it's like a fence Union bound
um and then the second Lemma
is that if we have such a sequences of
sets of strategies
like Promise To Us by Lemma one
then there is a choice function we can
choose small Si from Big SI and small TJ
from Big DJ
and the subsequence of the integers K1
K2 and so on
so that the metrics induced by these
by the by the S I's in these indices in
the DJs on these indices is exactly
Jewish poker
is an infinite triangular subnetics
okay
so you can think about it that in Lemma
1 we get this kind of a list version set
version of the Minimax where we have
this threshold R and the and then we
have a choice function that actually
rounds this to uh to a Minimax
and the Lemma 2 uses the the you know
uses Ramsey theorem this will give us
the choice function
and the one nice fact that I learned is
that Ramsey theorem and the Minimax
theorem was proven in the same year in
1928 almost 100 years ago
um
okay so let's uh let's sketch the proof
and any questions about these lemmas is
this uh
okay good
so let's uh let's prove Lemma one so
so in Lemma one we want to
to produce these sequences of sets of
strategies of size d
so
remember that we assume that M does not
satisfy the Minimax vom
so by assumption if you take in P sub Q
you get a larger number beta
then if you take the opposite so Q in
Phi right so if
if Max plays second he can get a higher
value than if mini plays the second
right
so I already tell you what is going to
be this threshold here it's just going
to be the average of Alpha and beta
okay
and now we need to produce this sequence
of sets
and we do it by induction so we we
construct them inductively
so assume we already produced S1 up to
SN and T1 up to TN and now we want to
construct s n plus 1 and we do do it as
follows
so consider the game where Max pure
strategies are restricted to the union
of the tis
okay so mini is not restricted you can
pick any strategy from capital S which
is infinite but Max is restricted only
to the union of the TI's
what can you tell me about this game
so so in this game we know that that Max
has a finite set of strategies because
HTI has size d so the total size is n
times d
so this game satisfies the Mini Max
and hence it has a value at most Alpha
why at most Alpha because mini here has
an advantage
and she could so she can guarantee the
the better value the which is most Alpha
she's not restricted
therefore because the Minimax is
satisfied so there exists some Universal
strategy for many
such that for every strategy of of marks
from the from these end sets of
strategies this mixed strategy of mini
guarantees uh winning probability
of at least one minus Alpha the win
probability of Max is at most Alpha
and so we have this randomized strategy
but for many and remember what we want
to do now is produce SN plus one which
is a set of pure strategies
so what we're going to do is to Simply
sample right what is the randomized
strategy the distribution of appeal
strategies so we're just going to sample
from these mixed strategies
so s n plus 1 is derived by sampling
strategies form p and p is guaranteed to
us from the Minimax
and in particular
um
it is enough to sample
the VC dimension of metrics I will it's
not important to to know the definition
of this dimension
over the the beta minus Alpha squared
okay so this is just the number that
arises from a calculation
but um
I do want to say something about it
because
um
okay so what what what do we know we
know that
if you sample
fix some strategy from the B from the
union of the TI's we know that P a
random strategy from p in expectation
achieves value of utmost Alpha
this means that if you take by turn off
if you take
log 1 over Delta over Epsilon squared
and you look at the at the make at the
at the at the
at the average strategy of the of the
strategies that you've sampled then
probability one minus Delta
it will it will give you a value of at
most Alpha plus Epsilon right by just a
simple term of boundary just sample
he used the fact that when you sample
from P then for a fixed strategy B you
win it with probability or you lose two
probability at most Alpha
then by turn off if you sample many
independent copies
then
the average of these copies is going to
to
load the probability at most Alpha plus
Epsilon and Epsilon Delta derived by
channels
now what we want to do here is to apply
Union bound right we want to to show the
the exists a good sampling from P that
holds simultaneously from for all the
strategies in the union of the TI's
but the issue is that there are there
are many strategies there that are n
times d
and we
we want to just have these strategies
not and not a function of n
and this is where the what I told you
before the Fancy Union bound comes into
play
so in particular here we use the
assumption that the Matrix M does not
contain a triangular segment recess of
more than a hundred by a hundred
oh 100 is just a content right
and therefore the VC dimension of this
Matrix is small and then VC Theory and
they don't want to get into it allows
you to do this Fancy Union bound and to
just uh and to get a number of samples
that is independent of the Union of the
TI's
so
so okay for those of you who are not
familiar with with visit Theory just
notice that here there is a subtle point
but this subtle is is quite standout
this point is quite standard it's not
it's nothing very
um yeah it's a standard argument
okay
and
and DN plus 1 is derived in in a
symmetric manner just in using the same
argument
um okay
so now let me explain how we how we
derive the second Lemma so let's first
recall what it says so now we already
have this S1 up to
these sequences of sets S1 S2 and so on
and T1 T2 and so on
and now we want to reason that there is
a way to choose a fuel strategy a
sequence of few strategies such as the
obtained game is uh is the Jewish poker
it's infinite triangular
so let's do it
so we are going to use his
um
the infinite version of Ramsey theorem
so let me first tell you what it says
so um
so the infinite version of Pharmacy
theorem we look at an infinite graph
here the the vertices of the graph will
be the natural numbers
and we have a coloring of the of the of
the edges right so we have a click over
the natural numbers and we color each
pair each each Edge in this click but
for my color
among finally many colors right so we
have maybe 20 colors and we call it each
Edge
by one of 20 colors
so the infinity Ramsey theorem will tell
us that there will be an infinite subset
of the vertices which which is
monochromatic such that all edges have
the same color
so um this is the
so this is this is the theorem we're
going to to use
so in particular we are going to
um to color the edges of the complete
graph of the natural numbers as follow
so for every so assume I is at most J so
we have a pair of edges an edge which is
a pair IJ
so we color it with this pair of binary
matrices it's the payoff Matrix when you
let s i play against TJ and the pair of
Matrix when you let SJ play against TI
now notice that crucially the number of
colors here is finite because we have
it's just a pair of d by D matrices
here it's really important that we that
we have this bound D on on the on the
size of the sets s i and TJ
so there are at most two to the 2 times
D Squared and many colors
yes so that's what I said so number of
colors is finite
so by Ramsay we have an infinite
monochromatic
subset of indices okay one K2 and so on
and now all is left to do is to
interpret what does monochromatic
means
in this context so let's do that
so
it means that there is a fixed pair of
two binary matrices
d by D binary matrices such that all
edges in this infinite set in this
infinite set of indices have this have
this
um payoffs
now notice that the value of M Prime by
assumption is less than R and the value
of n Prime by assumption is larger than
R this is by Lema one this is how we got
these sets
and therefore if you have a pair of
games a pair of binary matrices one has
a smaller value than the other then
there must be an entry in N Prime which
is zero where the corresponding entry in
M prime prime is one
right because other if you have a matrix
it completely dominates another metrics
and also the value of the dominating
Matrix will be larger
right so there must be a pair of indices
a b such as M Prime of a B zero whereas
n Prime of a B is 1.
and then we just set s i to be the
eighth strategy in Aki and TJ to be the
beat
strategy in bkj
and this is the again maybe this needs a
meditation but but it's it's really just
uh
just to digest the definitions and the
and and and and and and and
[Music]
um
and yeah and this gives you the the
second Lemma
and therefore the poof
yes so um
I'll be happy to take questions but I'm
done with the proof and the talk
thank you
account
yeah so thanks child for this very
theater talk so can you go back one
slide please
of course yeah just to make sure I
understand so this s i intjs these are
like pure strategies of this was a bit
confusing
yes yes yes so where
so you have uh so okay so
right so we have uh these sis
and then we S1 S2 and so on D1 T2 these
are subsets of size d of pure strategies
DSi is a now the mini strategies and the
and the teachers are sets of
of Max strategies
and then we find this monochromatic
infinite set so what does it mean it
means that if you look at the payoff
of of
ski and skj
so right so so all the payoffs yeah it's
a bit hard to
do you see my mouse
yes yes okay good so um
right so the the point is that if you
only restrict yourself to S I's and tjs
which are indexed by K1 K2 and so on
and you look at at this Vector of payoff
matrices then all of these vectors are
the same
right so
if you let sk1 play against tkq2 tk2 or
you let sk1 play against tk3
you get the same pair of metrics
as the binary metrics it will be the
same
so you have right so basically this this
infinite sequences of games have they
all have the same binary pair of
matrices depending on who plays first
right on whether I I smaller than J or
and and then we let M Prime and N Prime
be this pair of binary matrices that
describe the all of these games
and we know that the value of M Prime is
less than R and the value of M prime
prime is larger than R and and then
there is another simple argument saying
that there must be an entry
where n Prime is smaller than M Prime Pi
but smaller means that this one is zero
and the other one is one
because it's all binary
and hence if you take the eighth row
against the beat column in each of these
games
you get a zero and one according to
[Music]
um
or one and zero depending on who is who
is larger
I'm not sure if this was helpful but
more questions
yeah that's a thing try again
[Applause]
thank you
so let's have a 10 minute